[Music]
underneath the surface of Mars you may
have all the conditions you need for
life there may be some liquid water down
there and you're also protected from the
intense radiation that you find on the
surface scientists are split on the best
underground places to search for Martian
life but if Jani radabaugh were on Mars
she would head to the nearest sand dune
and start digging
here you can see this is wet sand just
below the surface this is the perfect
environment to be able to house life
even in the very driest deserts on earth
in between the sand dunes and the
introduced you can find water
percolating up from Springs that come up
from deep under the ground
perfect for life to form and grow and if
you just keep on digging down into the
bottom of the inner dune maybe you would
reach the water table and if you reach
the water table on Mars now you have all
the conditions just right for life this
is my bed this is where I go right
between the dunes digging for Martian
life in the desert is one option but
some scientists have very different
ideas and planetary scientist nina Lanza
would need to pack a rope and a
flashlight for her search so if I were
to go to Mars to find life I would go to
a lava tube lava tubes are made by
ancient volcanoes the empty leftovers
from underground lava flows
today they form deep tunnels shielded
from radiation and shut off from the
harsh Martian climate
we've never been in a lava tube on Mars
but it is absolutely possible that
there's liquid water so that's an
environment where you could have some
moisture you could have a little warmth
you're protected from radiation I think
that a Martian microbe would be very
happy there
finding any evidence whatsoever on Mars
would help us better understand what
else is possible
we'll the Martians be different than us
made from different materials and with a
different biochemistry or will they be
shockingly familiar
some scientists think at the very first
Martian life may not have stayed on Mars
it's not that far-fetched to think that
life could have jumped from Mars or bit
back and forth from Mars Earth could the
Martians have seeded life on our planet
maybe the Martians aren't dead maybe I'm
a Martian maybe you're a Martian
you